what's more likely for week seven of the
2020 season the giants and the eagles
what's more likely chris daniel jones
throws two or more touchdown passes or
boston scott reaches 100 plus yards from
scrimmage miles sanders by the way out
this week with a knee problem well
what's more likely i'll i'll um
i think i'd i'd have to go with boston
scott here i do i mean there's just
there's limited weapons
on the eagles the way they
have their offense planned out you know
erts folgum
and scott will be the third option we
saw last year the the one thing he was
very good at was in the past game to
where i think that's where he'll get
over that you know that'll help him get
over that hundred yard plus scrimmage uh
mark but you know daniel jones two tds
they're gonna have some opportunities
but man their offense is struggling they
don't pass protect well
they don't have a lot of great receivers
to get open down the field that way
so i'm gonna go with boston scott
yeah i agree with you i just don't have
a whole lot of faith in the giants
offense i know they beat washington but
i i need to see a hell of a lot more it
was 13 out of daniel jones washington
was driving down the field right and
that's when they got the strip sack
fumble
and and they call it a strip sack
i i
i still don't know that it was a strip
sack per se it almost looked like
quarterback coughs the ball up yeah like
like throws it like i like it almost
qualified as a forward pass
that fumble so it was just kind of a
strange thing all right the steelers 5-0
at the titans 5. i know the original
game that was postponed as a result of
the pandemic and it's even bigger now
that both teams are at 5-0 as they get
ready to meet what's more likely derek
henry gets 120 or more rushing yards or
he's held to under 80. you can't you
can't pick a number between 81 and 119.
what is it 120 or more or 80 or less i'm
going to go under 80. i am i i just the
steelers they're not going to let the
run game go that's not they're not going
to be cool with that like oh go ahead
run the ball on us then you can just do
everything i think they're going to go
no we'll stop the run
we'll take our chances with the pass
game things like that see where it goes
there but i just you know mike tomlin
they're defensive guys
old school defensive guys i just have a
hard time thinking they're gonna
they're gonna let him get off that way
now it stinks that devin bush got hurt
in the middle of their defense i mean
he's a really good football player but
i'll tell you
this damn kid that came in for him um i
don't i don't want to mess up his name
or whatever
he was impressive looking
i'm hopeful for him but i that front
seven still it's it's the best in
football or certainly one of the two or
three best i'm going to go with under 80
rushing yards
and and here's the thing yeah
what's the game plan going to be for the
tennessee titans so they're going to try
to to power derrick henry into the line
like they always do and are they just
going to say you're trying to take derek
henry away we're going to let ryan
tannehill go out and do his thing or
maybe it's going to be derek henry
catching passes not running into the
teeth of that defense so they may not
try to get 120 or more yards out of
derek henry this week chris well yeah i
i mean i i don't think they're gonna
like bang their head against it they're
always gonna try and work through that
but they're never too stubborn to where
you go
like the buffalo bills game the other
week buffalo had everybody by the line
of scrimmage they were just like okay
fine you know we'll run the ball to keep
giannis but man every time we drop back
to pass we're gashing you with play
action passes and 15 and 20 yard gains
and that's where they're awesome right
now so you know they'll they'll
they always want to play through henry
it's just going to be okay we're going
to continue to play for him or do we
have to adjust and start to play off of
him and use him more as a decoy that's
where they'll have to make that decision
at some point in the first quarter with
how the steelers are playing them
there's
there's one flaw
in derek henry's game yeah
and it's that it takes him a couple of
steps to go down no doubt and if you can
swarm to him before he gets ahead of
steam and knock him down
that's your only chance if you let him
get those first two or three steps he's
either gonna run past you or he's going
to run through you or he's going to
stiff-arm you into the ground or you're
going to make a business decision and
run the other way and there's nobody on
that steelers team that's going to make
any business decisions they're going to
be going after derek henry and they're
going to be coached all week long to get
him
asafp the moment he gets the ball in his
hands otherwise you let him get going
and you got a problem i like that little
f in there in the a-s-a-f-b
i don't know what you're talking about
that was very smooth to you very smooth
but you're right
and to your point about him being a
little bit of a you know gain some
momentum type runner that's where
pittsburgh is amazing there's no tail
lawn at left tackle now because of the
acl that's a little concerning and
pittsburgh is a chaos front
they want to create chaos to where
you're like whoa we don't know which way
you're going you've messed up our
blocking and then the running back's
indecisive too because it all looks
crazy to him you know he might pop one
but i i think more than likely they're
going to be all over him and and ready
to go
speaking of the pittsburgh defense
something i noticed watching the browns
steelers game and we talked about this
last night on pftpm i want to get your
thoughts on this yeah
and and and the the angle for that game
seemed like wider so you could see the
whole pittsburgh defense right on on
every snap
there's something about them pre-snap
there's a swagger to them pre-snap the
way they move there's a certainty yes
and i think that in and of itself has
got to be intimidating for an offense
and i think i think mika fitzpatrick
knew what was coming on the play where
he got the pick six if you watch that
closely he goes right to the spot he
takes two steps he's got the ball and
he's gone and i noticed that over and
over again especially in the secondary
the linebackers in the secondary there's
just a certainty and a confidence and an
attitude to the way they move before the
snap that would freak me out if i was
the quarterback no doubt they know how
to mess with the quarterback and you
know mess with disguises and oh yeah you
know we're the big bad steelers i'm
walking over here you better be ready
let's set hut and all of a sudden he
drops back to you know the deep safety
and you're like wait you know that's
that is the beauty of the pittsburgh
defense it's confusing it makes you
think a lot they got
you know they're one of the worldwide
leaders and big bad mofos on a defense
to where it just so it's the trifecta
and they are uh they're special that way
but is that something that affected you
as a quarterback you could walk up to
the line of scrimmage and look over
there and see all these guys who are
very certain and very confident and and
just very aware of where they're gonna
be and you don't know where they're
gonna be i never had to play and start
against that ravens defense
but i can make the correlation to the
baltimore ravens who are the similar way
with ray lewis and ed reed
and yeah you're constantly wait what are
they are they in this defense is he
gonna blitz this guy do i need to check
their protection all of those type of
things it's really important to have a
kind of a simple game plan in a lot of
ways just to make so the quarterback
doesn't have to overthink uh yeah but
but even
in my experience being on a team playing
pittsburgh because their defense hasn't
really changed you know that was always
what we were worried about the tennessee
titans back in 2008 best team in the afc
we're playing the steelers we've talked
about the game before i got to be troy
palomalo during the week and some of the
practices and walkthroughs because
that's all we were worried about was
like that minka fitzpatrick thing you're
talking about man where is he gonna be
where is he gonna end up you know let's
not let him influence us checking a play
here there's a little signal that they
might go to this coverage so let's not
run into some play and change it and
then they get out of it and play some
other defense
it's the most concerning thing that you
have to deal with uh when you play the
steelers
how the hell did you end up playing troy
palamalla for the scout well they just
they knew like i was you know a football
nerd and i've you know i was still at
that point i'm ron jaworski and i've
watched the film and they could they i
had a good idea of kind of how he moved
around and if he was going to play this
coverage he'd be over here and then end
up over there and kerry collins liked
how i did it so i think he kept telling
them hey put him back there he's giving
us a good look and all that and he's
making it hard on us and uh it helped
hopefully we won also free advice
something we should have mentioned last
night to derek henry when we had him on
pftpm if it goes well on sunday against
the steelers stay away from the terrible
towels
don't mess around don't stomp don't jinx
yourself 2008 right no absolutely not
one more from that game what's more
likely ryan tannehill throws three
touchdowns and no picks or ben
roethlisberger throws three touchdowns
in no pick wow
whoa
man i i mean ryan tannehill is so on
fire and is so good i i really i think
if i'm gonna choose one here i'm gonna
go with ben roethlisberger one i'm not
totally sure i buy into the steelers run
game yet right i mean it looked good
last week and i hope they can continue
it but i'm just not going to buy into it
yet and we've seen the tennessee titans
will give you some opportunities to make
some plays in the pass game and i think
because of that if you make me choose
one of the other
i'll go with big ben i could see ryan
tano throw over three touchdowns but
maybe an interception and getting fooled
one play by that steelers defense or
something like that
ben did not have big numbers last week
but he had two big throws and he
manipulated the defense with his eyes
and his body language in each of them he
looked right and got chase claypool in
single coverage because andrew sandejo
faded over to the right and then he did
a pump on the touchdown to james
washington that allowed washington to be
basically uncovered in the end zone
because everything flowed the way so
he's still one of the best guys and i
agree with you i think it's more likely
to be him with three and zero big
receiver matchup in the desert on sunday
the seahawks at the cardinals what's
more likely dk metcalf has a hundred or
more receiving yards or deandre hopkins
has a hundred or more receiving yards
man they're both awesome um
i'm gonna go with dk
i'm gonna go with dk
um
you know cover corners
with arizona and just the way they play
lately with hopkins hey it was great at
first but i you know
it hasn't been a machine that way and i
like i've told you i think people are
catching on
to that that cardinals offense a little
bit
um but i would think between seattle
having a week off knowing they're
playing arizona
a little extra time on hey let's not
deandre hopkins get off on us i'm gonna
go with dk metcalf gets the hundred
yards
and the seahawks have two weeks to get
ready for this one yeah that's makes it
different and also the seahawks are
going to remember what happened late
last year when they're trying to win the
division and the cardinals come to town
and put one on them a little payback is
going to be in order i don't want to get
ahead jamal adams right he'll be about
our picks he may yeah he
well we'll find out with the injury
reports today but the indications where
he'd be back from the groin strain in
time for this game against the cardinals
but hopkins has 100.2 receiving yards
per game leading the nfl metcalf has
99.2 yards per game he's in second place
but i'm with you i think it's gonna be
metcalf on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports